let me pull up this video oh boy this
one's going to get us in trouble so we
got this from nicholas fonda caro he's
over at uh mrc newsbusters
he says how dare you whoopi whoopi
goldberg ridiculously pops off against
bill maher for anti-mask jokes tells him
to stay out of society sarah haynes
joins in by saying masks will be a
permanent new normal like airport
security after 9 11. i may never feel
comfortable without a mask even after
the bill maher barry weiss thing comes
out the liberals are like we're not
going to be doing this
the view is still doubling down but i'm
bringing this up for a different reason
i want you all to listen very closely
you ready
bananas you are
that's
not really funny to people who have lost
their kids
to this vaccine of people who've lost
family
that's
not really funny to people who've lost
their kids
to this vaccine or people who've lost
family members or
dear friends to this it's it's just you
know i'm gonna play that one more time
one more time for you guys
you are
that's
not really funny to people who've lost
their kids
to this vaccine or people who've lost
family members or
dear friends to this it's it's just you
know listen nobody on the planet really
wants to go through this this
you know
everybody responds to that when i
tweeted it saying whoa
whoopi goldberg said
losing your kids to the vaccine
and everyone said you know what she
meant you know what she meant and they
always do that and i'm like
if we were a serious people in this
country i would
but she says nobody wants this and
nobody wants to go through with this did
she mean to say virus
yeah
why do you how do you know
um how do you how do you know what she
was thinking uh
only because i've seen her work and i
and i feel like that's what she meant to
say and that she misspoke this is a big
problem we have in the information
space
exemplified by a tweet i made about a
rumor going around that a school had put
litter boxes in the bathroom for furries
i quoted a woman who said that she had
heard a school had put litter boxes in
their bathroom for kids who identified
as furries
and i linked to a story where it says
superintendent denies this
and everybody interpreted the tweet
however they wanted to
many people on the right interpret it to
mean the story was true and they were
doing this
many interpreted it to mean that people
are insane for believing it and many
interpret it to believe that i was
actually personally believing the story
had happened and it was true without
fact-checking
that's the problem with you ian saying
you know what whoopi goldberg meant when
she said this i wouldn't like risk my
life on it but i that's my guess i think
it's fair no no i do agree though i do
agree though i think she meant to say
virus or whatever but the problem is
right now what would they do if it was
like donald trump making a statement
if donald trump came out and said did
you see this
whoopi goldberg says kids being lost to
the vaccine
what's going on with the view the media
would say false never happened but then
someone will take the clip of her saying
it
and they'll play it and she literally
did say people have lost their kids to
the vaccine yeah now look don't make me
get into it youtube i don't i'm not here
to make a medical conversation just go
people can talk to their doctors as
youtube mandates we say or whatever the
point is
i just thought this was really
fascinating that she literally said this
no one on the show corrects her as far
as i know they never came out and said
we really need to clarify that statement
for national television
because as far as i could tell if you
would take a transcript of this and just
show what she was saying
she's criticized criticizing vaccines
she just got covered right like a couple
weeks ago or something so she's probably
really twisted about this whole thing
and she's got a job to do going on the
view but obviously something's going on
in her head that that that that came out
well it's not even that i mean the whole
segment itself is bonkers where they're
like uh one that one woman what's her
name sarah haines is like i'm not gonna
leave my house ever even after the
pandemic fine it's like are you trying
to one up the other crazy karen ladies
is this new it's more yes it's from
today yeah yeah wow it's it's it's like
you know people are constantly trying to
one-up each other you know so you get
some woman who's like i i like the mask
you guys remember when wasn't it david
hogg who was like uh
i'm not gonna take the mask off because
people think i'm a republican or
something like that yeah yeah
and and that goes to what we've been
saying right this is a lot of this is
virtual signaling it's it's
i need to do something so that people
don't associate me with the wrong people
and if that is
what is driving any part of your public
health response
we're in trouble because i mean one of
the things i heard and again culvert has
just scrambled everything in american
sort of political life it's
when it first hit why isn't trump doing
enough then it's
trump is a is a is a you know fascist
and a dictator and he's gonna do too
much and now it's i want i want the
government to tell me what to do
who i can have at my house on the fourth
of july or thanksgiving or christmas and
i don't think people know what to think
and i do think
many brains have been scrambled you know
talking about you know i just did this
stupid youtube disclaimer thing because
like we don't give medical advice here
on this show go speak to your doctor
what's about what's right for you i
wonder what people how people are going
to respond when all of this implodes
because it's already starting to implode
i mentioned several times i'm like i
don't even know what the rules are
anymore because the media the news has
reported such crazy things like the new
york times israeli study says that
repeated uh vaccination could actually
increase your chance of catching the
virus or whatever someone like it could
reduce the the immune response i'm like
there yeah and i'm like can i talk about
that can i say that because youtube will
vanish i don't know man i read in the
new york times go talk to a doctor don't
get your advice from me but what happens
when regular people
who uh like like hassan the the lefty
streamer he refers to people as
ivermectin truthers
how do people who watch him react when
all of this implodes and the narrative
crumbles and then just
we realize once again who was actually
corrected are people gonna gonna be mad
at youtube and these big tech companies
feel like they've been deceived when
will people start to i know that we do
but when will regular people start to
look at twitter and be like yo these
people are evil they're manipulating us
they're lying about what's going on and
they're controlling the flow of
information probably never because like
we just last week talked about only two
percent of the american population even
uses twitter most people are not savvy
facebook maybe facebook but like
whatever
yeah well not everybody but a lot of
people younger people
but tick tock even we're banned from
tick tock wow yeah yeah i don't know why
i don't know i think it's because we had
alex jones on yes i mean
my experience and and i'll say this sort
of from the race angle i've seen so many
stories that have blown up that have
been complete hoaxes and there's always
a remnant of people who hold on to it
for dear life i mean i know
the one that comes to mind is you know
the the michael brown shooting in
ferguson
and the whole hands up don't shoot thing
that went sort of international
and then
barack obama and eric holders doj did
their investigation and they found they
couldn't find a single witness
um who had who had sort of testimony or
or an interview that corroborated the
forensic evidence that showed that
michael brown was shot with his hands up
in a position of surrender i mean i read
through the entire report
now
there are still politicians i think
elizabeth warren and kamala harris who
every time michael brown's birthday
comes around they talk about it as if he
was murdered in cold blood so some
people will never let go of that um
yeah and and and when you see
i mean i think there was a study last
year that showed that
people who identify as liberal and very
liberal
overestimate the number of police
shootings of unarmed black men i mean
the very liberal thing is like between a
thousand and ten thousand so some
somebody did a video i remember who it
was it might have been vice where they
went to they went around l.a and asked
people
how many black people do you think have
been killed by police in the past year
they went to the venice skate park and
these these skater guys they were like
500 a thousand
10 000
what was it like 13
unarmed yeah it's typically in that
range and even
i think most people would vastly
overestimate the percentage of sort of
police shooting fatalities that even
involve black black people it's on
average it's about 25 percent 45 of
police shooting fatalities are white
people typically white men
but if you read
if if you were someone that came from
mars you would think only black men get
shot by the cops and only white blondes
go missing now what if you're a 10 year
old in 2008
you're on facebook and buzzfeed pops up
and the only thing you see in your
facebook feed for 10 years
is police brutality videos yeah now it's
2018 your vote in the midterm for the
first time
and you're probably screaming like
cops are going around hunting people
down using terms like genocide i mean we
we have been primed and unless you're a
person
who
can think critically this is where being
a sheep is so dangerous because if you
just take the word of cnn
or msnbc or even for that period of time
the whole colin kaepernick thing was hot
espn
you are being fed by low information
journalists quote unquote and political
analysts and commentators
and
what you're being fed basically is
synthetic grass and if you feed a sheep
synthetic grass they're going to die
period
yeah man
i think about this uh the social media
problem i i really do think twitter
is one of the biggest causes of these
problems of everything we're
experiencing the rapid out of context
the rapid spread of decontextualized
information whether intentionally false
or otherwise
the whoopi goldberg clip
the reason i want to highlight this and
talk about her miss speaking is because
they never corrected it right and so
what could happen now is i i guarantee
you there will be people who will clip
her saying that and they're going to be
like breaking whoopi goldberg criticizes
vaccine
and she literally said it she did and it
makes sense to me that that would be a
kind of a freudian slip but at the same
time i really hate when people assume
they know what other people are thinking
because we don't even understand what we
we're thinking ourselves have the time
communicating is not perfect between
humans talking saying the things that
you actually think is very challenging
so give her the benefit of the doubt a
little bit but the fact that no one
corrected her on this somebody should
have been like no the dying of the virus
yeah what a bunch of weak minds no
offense girls or guys or whoever's on
that show to not correct her on that no
listen to your co-hosts and correct them
when they misspeak it's crazy isn't it
nobody wanted to speak up and be like
whoopi whoopee did you mean did you like
when you when you said wolf in shepherd
yeah i was like wait did you mean
like hey we're having a real
conversation i'll ask you to clarify
it's no big deal they could have been
like whoopi did you mean the virus you
said you said vaccine she would have
been like oh yeah that's right yeah okay
great no now that clips around that
clips out i love what you just said
about how twitter might be making people
nuts i just made a video on mines about
this first video i've made in a while
about tone and i think tone has been
lost and basically as a human society
we're evolving our communication
abilities then we developed the phone
and we were able to communicate via
vocal vibration then all of a sudden we
develop internet video and we can
communicate but people have fallen back
into text again like they're sending
letters again and it's driving them it's
like the stone age man get out keep
moving forward do not fall back into
text
you're missing the tone twitter is awful
it's the text if you if there's video
conversation i'm all for it but
people
type like it's 1911. but what's the
alternative right you know i've been
thinking about this the internet has
allows shows like this that allows us to
communicate with each other allows us to
fact check and challenge the
establishment more than ever before but
it also gives the establishment the
ability to propagandize and manipulate
better than ever before true yeah and i
mean those are the
the trade-offs that come with any sort
of complex system or any public policy
or any advancement in technology it's
always going to be trade-offs the
question is net-net is it do we think
it's
to our benefit as a society or is it to
our detriment and i think i think it's a
good question it's i think it's clear
it's a benefit that's why they're trying
so hard to censor everything yeah and
control the flow of information because
you want to induce yourself with
information whether it's right or wrong
and a strong mind can wield all sorts of
information without believing it and
that you have to but
but you can also be brainwashed even the
strongest of minds if you induce
yourself with enough false narrative it
can start to change you you know we're
susceptible so
how do you balance that what how do you
balance it i mean for me part of this
goes to
the importance of education
right and starting for kids but i see
education is equal part scholarship and
discipleship but also
a lifelong process not something that
ends at
in 12th grade when you turn 18.
so part of it i just have a number of
filters right i always try to get a
comment in context so whenever possible
i look for a longer stream of thought if
if it's a clip video
um
i always i have different sort of areas
of absolute truth so no matter how many
people line up and tell me
that
caitlyn jenner is a woman i'm not going
to call a person who is a biological
male a she i know that may get me banned
from certain platforms but it is what it
is so
i'm just trying to keep my feet firmly
planted on the ground and not lose track
of reality thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00
pm
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time